[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قتل ضابط شرطه مصري واصيب مجند
في هجوم استهدف سيارتهما في محافظه الجيزه
وذلك غذاه اصابه ثلاثه سياح اوروبيين في
هجوم نفذه شابان على فندق بالغردقه وبعد
يومين من هجوم اخر على حافله ركاب سياحيه
في القاهره تضاربت الروايات الرسميه بشانه
واعلن تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه تبنيه نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في محورين ما دلاله
تكرار وقوع هذه الهجمات وما سر تركيزها
على استهداف الامنيين والمواقع
السياحيه وما هي التداعيات المحتمله لهذه
الهجمات التي تاتي قبل اي ايام من ذكرى 25
يناير ثلاث هجمات خلال ثلاثه ايام فقط
حملتها عناوين الاحداث في مصر موقعين
موقعين سياحيين او موقعين سياحيين في
الجيزه والغردقه بينما استهدف الثالث ضابط
شرطه ومجندا فاردا هما قتيلين تضاربت
الروايات الرسميه بشان حادثي الجيزه
والغردقه بين تاكيد على الطبيعه الارهابيه
لكليهما اول الامر ثم التراجع ومحاوله
ردهما لاسباب جنائيه بعد ذلك وحتى تتضح
اسباب او اهداف هذا الارتباك في الروايه
الرسميه لما حدث يبقى التساؤل بشان وقوع
هذه الهجمات قبيل ذكرى ال من يناير وما
سبقه من دعوات للتظاهر والاحتجاج ضد
النظام
المصري ضابط برتبه عقيد قالت الداخليه
المصريه انه رئيس رس شرطه المرور في
المنيب جنوب الجيزه ومرافقه المجند لقيا
مصرعهما على يد مسلحين لاذو بالفرار عقد
وزير الداخليه اجتماعا مع ضباطه الكبار
وتعهد بضبط الجن وتقديمهم للعداله عباره
تذيل في العاده اخبار الجرائم العاديه في
حين كان تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه يتبنى
الهجوم ببيان يشبه اعلان حرب مفتوحه ويسخر
بعبارات الوعيد لما يدعوه الطاغوت وازلامه
وفق مفرداته قبل ذلك بيوم هجوم ملتبس على
فندق في الغردقه السياحيه تتضارب الروايات
حوله الى الان قالت مصادر رسميه ان مسلحين
هاجما واوقع اصابات من بينهم سائحان
اجنبيان وان احد المنفذين قتل واصيب الاخر
لكن الفندق اصدر بيانا نفى فيه اي شبهه
عمل ارهابي اللبس نفسه لف هجوما في
القاهره على حافله تقل سياحا من بينهم عرب
من مناطق الخط الاخضر اعلن تنظيم الدوله
مسؤوليته عنه في حين قالت الحكومه انه عمل
جنائي اين الحقيقه في مشهد مصر المعقد
هناك اكثر من وجه لاكثر الاشياء وجل
الامور خاضع للسياسه ما يدفع كثيرين للنظر
بارتياب الى شفافيه البيانات الرسميه لكن
تتابع الوقائع وتوقيتها قبل ايام من ذكرى
ثوره يناير يفتح من جديد جدليه الامن
والسلطه
[موسيقى]
وبمعية ويفاخر وفي حين يتمسك مصريون كثر
بالنظام الحالي خوفا من المجهول او
باعتباره حاميا لهم من الارهاب منذ كان
محتملا يرى كثر اخرون ان ما يجري يتجاوز
كونه خللا في منظومه الامن الى خلل على
مستوى الدوله التي يرفع شعار الحفاظ عليها
منذ الانقلاب العسكري ذريعه لتجريف الحياه
العامه السويه في ارجائها وفي التطبيق
تذهب السلطه في اتجاهات عنيفه فتمارس اقصى
درجات القمع السياسي المولد انسانيا
لاحباط وقهر لدى ملايين الناس بما يعزز
قيام عنف مضاد وفق قانون طبيعي يقول ان
حصاد الزرع من جنس
النبته موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا في
تورنتو الدكتور ثروه نافع عضو لجنه الدفاع
والامن القومي في مجلس الشورى المصري
السابق ومن القاهره عبر الهاتف محمود عطيه
المحامي والمنسق العام لائتلاف مصر فوق
الجميع اهلا بضيفي الكريمين سيد محمود
عطيه ضيفي من
القاهره ما تفسير هذا الارتباك الذي وقع
في تتبع احداث كالتي وقعت في فندق في
الارض الغردقه روايه بشكل معين ثم تتطور
الى النهايه بشكل مختلف تماما عما تم سرده
في البدايه بين هل كان الذي جرى سياسيا ام
كان
جنائيا
استاذ عبد القاب خليني اقول لحضرتك ان مصر
طبعا معروف بتتعرض لارهاب مش مش على
المستوى المحلي بس ده ارهاب
عالمي ودي
جرزان من الاخر بعد العمليات الكبيره التي
قامت بها القوات المسلحه والشرطه
المصريه فاذا كان هناك حادثه او اخرى لان
مصر مستهدفه وخصه وصل لضرب السياحه ا فحمد
لله الجهات
الامنيه بتبدل الجهد وراء الجهد في القضاء
على هؤلاء
الجرزان في القريب الع هذا جيد سيد محمود
هذا جيد ولكن فقط اجبني على سؤالي ما الذي
يجعل هذا المستوى من الارتباك في وصف ما
يجري البدايه قالوا بان الشابين ينتميان
الى تنظيمات ارهابيه ردد شعارات ويحملون
بعض الشعارات لت تهي المساله في النهايه
ويبقى السؤال معلقا انها مساله جنائيه
وليست سياسيه ما الذي يخلق هذا الارتباك
في حدث مثل
هذا احتمال اصل ا استاذ عبد القادر
الابحري يبقى في اكتر من مندوب واكثر من
مراسل بيحتاجوا يعملوا سبق صحفي يبقوا اول
ناس بلغوا القنوات بتاعته لكن احنا في مصر
ا بنعتمد دائما على بيانات وزاره الداخليه
وده
البيان المسلم فاذا قالت وزاره الداخليه
انه عمل
اجرامي جنائي وليس ارهابي فنحن مع وزاره
الداخليه اذا قالت ان هو لان هم يعرفوا
اكثر من منها يعني هم عندهم المعلومات
والبيانات والخرائط اكتر منها ا مافيش
ارتباك ولا ولا شيء ولا حاجه هي هي
المراسلين بيبقوا عايزين كل واحد بياخد اي
معلومه يعني امبارح انا كان عندي حلقه في
التلفزيون واحنا بنتكلم مراسل قال ان في
ناس قتلوا من السواح بعديه مراسل اخر قال
لا ان ماحدش
قتل واحد ثالث قال ان في حد طبعا هنا لا
اتكلم عن ما ينقله المراسلون سيد محمود
ولكن عنما تقوله جهات رسميه امنيه عن
سردها لتطور العمليه دكتور ثروت في تتبع
بيان لطبيعه العمليات سواء في السنه
الماضيه او بدايه هذه السنه هناك تركيز
على عناصر في الامن وكذلك على اهداف
سياحيه ما دلاله ذلك
برايك لا هي الدلاله الاولى هي دليل اخر
على فشل وقله كفاءه المنظومه الامنيه في
مصر وده ليه عده اسباب اهمها هو التركيز
على الامن السياسي كما كان يحدث منذ ايام
حسني مبارك ثم عاد بعد الانقلاب العسكري
فانت في حقيقه الامر كدوله كل الدول معرضه
لهجمات ارهابيه وخاصه تزايد فكره الارهاب
مع وجود داعش في الفتره الاخيره بما فيهم
الدول المتقدمه والدول المتحضره لكن
كلهم يعني بيوجه منظومتهم الامنيه
وتدريبهم وكفاءتهم في القضاء او التتبع
لهؤلاء او محاوله حتى ضح هم قبل ان تبدا
عمليات ارهابيه والا كان حتر مجازر يوميه
في اوروبا وفي امريكا وفي دول اخرى لكن هي
من الكفاءه كفاءه المنظومه الامنيه هي
اللي بتقلل هذه الحوادس اما بالنسبه لمصر
فمع ضعف هذه الكفاءه نتيجه ان الامن ما
فيش منظومه حقيقيه يعني انت هتلاقيهم
يتتبع مثلا الناشطين السياسيين سواء كانوا
شباب او طلبه جامعه هتلاقيهم بيسجلوا لهم
في بيوتهم هتلاقيهم بيقبضوا عليهم في
البيت ويقولوا لهم في قانون التظاهر وخدوا
من بيته هتلاقيه حاططهم على الانتربول هو
مشغول دائما بالحفاظ على الكرسي وبالحفاظ
على السلطه وليس مسؤول بالمنظومه الامنيه
لمصر ولذلك تجد في مصر المرور فاشل تجد في
مصر الجوازات فاشله تجد في مصر المنظومه
الامنيه للمواطن هي منظومه فاشله بكل
المقاييس وما يتبع ذلك كان اخطر بعد
الانقلاب في انه حتى المنظومه منظومه
الدفاع او منظومه الجيش اصبح الجيش يعني
يوجه في اتجاه المحافظه على الكيان
السياسي اكثر من المحافظه على الحدود
وتدخل الجيش في السياسه فاضعف يعني قيمه
التواج
دكتور لماذا
لماذا لماذا توصف المنظومه الامنيه في مصر
بالفشل وما تنفذه جماعات توصف بالارهابي
في دول اخرى ايضا لازالت اعمالها مستمره
وتنفذ عمليات رغم الاجراءات الامنيه
المتخذه ما الذي يجعل وصفك لما تقوم به
المنظومه الامنيه في مصر بهذا
المستوى لان لان طريقه التنفيذ حتى في
العمليات الارهابيه بتقوم في مصر طريقه
بدائيه جدا وطريقه كان يمكن ان هي يعني لا
تحدث في معظم الاحيان اما في العمليات
اللي بيتم حدثها في الدول اللي فيها
منظومه امنيه حقيقيه وسليمه بتجد العمليه
كانت مور سوستك تد والاعداد ليها كان اكثر
تنظيما زي مثلا انت حضرتك لو ذكرت العربيه
اللي اضربت عربيه الامن اللي اتضربت في
برض على مدخل القاره من قيمه شهر او شهر
ونص والناس قاعدين ما معهمش والامين
الشرطه واقف بعيد بيقول لك انا الطبنجه
بتاعتي ما بتشتغلش كل ده معلوم لدى
المواطن المصري العادي وكل ده معلوم لدى
الجماعات الارهابيه ثم قائد الانقلاب
حينما جاء في 3 يوليو قال يعني اعطوني
تفويضا وانا ساقضي على الارهاب المحتمل
فاذا بالارهاب يزداد حتى داخل مصر يعني
داعش دي لم تكن متواجده او هؤلاء يعني
دعني انقل ضيفي من القاهره محمود عطيه ما
ذكرته الان ان كان ما يجري الى الص نعم هو
تكريس لفشل رغم الوعود بمحاربه الارهاب ام
ان هناك امر واقع سيد محمود ما تفسير ان
العمليات مستمره رغم كل ما يتم اجراءه من
ملاحقات من من عمليات مكثفه وبشكل قوي ومع
ذلك ما زالت هناك عمليات تنفذ وفي مواقع
حساسه وحساسه جدا
كالمواد لحضرتك ان ده ارهاب دولي التشكيك
في في في الامن المصري ده غير مقبول طبعا
وخاصه لما
يكون المتحدث مصري
ايضا شفنا وشاهدنا وسمعنا على قناه
الجزيره ا حادثه
فرنسا منذ ايام
معدوده حصل تحذير للمستشاره الالمانيه
ميركل بانها لا تذهب الى مكتبها فالمسائل
دي يعني موجوده في العالم كله احنا بنحاول
في مصر الامن
شغال ببطاقه كبيره بكل
المتاح بياخدوه
بجديه نحن نشعر في في مصر وفي القاهره وفي
باقي المحافظات بفرق كبير
جدا من من ثلاث سنين او اربع سنين التقدم
الاهي في
في في صعود دائم فانا انا يعني انا انا مش
شايف ان انا احمل الدوله و اذا كان هناك
اشخاص بيدعوا او لهم وجهه نظر في ما جرى
في مصر انقلاب عسكري ومش ع هذا راي لكن مش
مش معناها كيف تفسر كيف تفسر عدم قدرات
الاجهزه الامنيه المصريه في حمايه مواقع
سياحيه هامه في مصر وهي ايضا مورد دخل
كبير الاقتصاد المصري الذي يعاني
اصلا استاذ محمود السم سالتك ما تفسيرك
لعدم استطاعه المنظومات او القوه الامنيه
في مصر ان توفر الحمايه اللازمه لمواقع
سياحيه هامه في
مصر استحاله استحاله يا استاذ عبد القاد
ان ان ان جهاز امني في الحاله اللي احنا
فيها في العالميه مش المصريه بس انه ما
تحصلش بعض الاشياء المحتمله برض يعني
المحتمله لان داعش بتهدد وداعش دخلت في
اكثر من مكان طبعا بدا عاي امريكا وسبب
امريكا ولما نقرا الكتاب بتاع السيده هلري
كلينتون الخيارات الصعبه ونشوفه بتعترف ان
امريكا اللي عملت داعش و فاحنا امام مخطط
رهيب جدا لمصر والدول العربيه مش مصر طبعا
الاستشهاد الاستشهاد عفوا سيد محمود بما
جاء في كتاب ما ذكرته الان السيده هيلاري
كلينتون طبعا في جزء كبير من الكلام
المغروف ولم تقله اصلا السيده كلينتون
وبالتالي البناء على موضوع مثل هذا يعني
ليس في مصلحه من يقدمه
كدليل يعني الكتاب الكتاب يا استاذ الكتاب
الكتاب مزور الكتاب المترجم اللي بيتباع
في في المكتبات وان كان هذا ليس موضوع انا
ولكن كلنتون لم تقل بان امريكا هي من صنعت
داعش كما ذكرت قبل قليل اتوجه ساعود لك
ولكن فقط اذهب الى ضيفي الدكتور ثروه نافع
فيما يتعلق ب تواصل هذه العمليات واستهداف
اماكن بهذه الحساسيه في مصر وعدم توفي الا
لقطاع هام من قطاع اقتصادي مهم هو قطاع
السياحه ما تاثير ذلك على هذه المنظومه
الامنيه وكذلك على اقتصاد مصر برايك دكتور
ثروت هو اكبر دليل ان هذه المناطق
السياحيه بالذات الفنادق وما الى ذلك كلنا
نعلم كمصريين يعني وكل من ظار مصر ان
المناطق دي بتبقى مؤمنه اكثر من غيرها
يعني عندك ميتال ديتكتورز وعندك بيبقى
شرطه السياحه قبل ما تخش الهوتيل والك ده
موجود فدليل ان هم يخرقوا ذلك بسهوله
شديده هو ده بيثبت الدلاله الاولانيه اللي
انا قلتها لحضرتك هو فشل المنظومه الامنيه
الشكليه في مصر يعني انت لما تيجي في
باريس او في اوروبا او في امريكا او في
كندا مافيش الاوتيلات ماليهاش لميتال
ديتكتورز و الى ذلك فلو لو الامن كان ضعيف
والارهاب موجود في كل الدول وفي هذه الدول
اكثر لو لو المنظومه الامنيه ضعيفه كانت
هتلاقي كل يوم حوادث من دي قدها 20 مره
لكن اللي بيتطلب بيكون له ترتيب شديد جدا
وطبعا ارهاب موجود في كل حته لكن لما
بيكون الدول ضعيفه زي المنظومه الامنيه
بتاعتها بيحدث العمليات بياف زي اللي
بتحصل في مصر ف التاثير على السياحه خطير
لان احنا دوله بتعتمد من احد يعني يعني
الاركا ركائزها الاساسيه في الاقتصاد هو
الدخل السياحي بالاضافه لدخل قناه السويس
والضرايب والعاملين بالخارج العاملين
بالخارج قللوا طبعا بعد هروب الناس وبعد
نفي الناس وبعد ما يحدث في الاقتصاد قناه
السويس لن تزداد ولن تزيد كما قلنا في حتى
في في الج والاقتصاديه من التفريعه
الجديده بل بالعكس ازادت العبء على مصر
بانهم بيستلف دلوقتي مليارات والسياحه
طبعا مع عدم الاستقرار السياسي ومع تطور
الارهاب بانه بس يعني بيزداد وبيخرج من
المساحه الضيقه لسيناء وفي بعض المناطق في
سيناء مع ازدياده بدخوله الى العاصمه هو
علامه ايضا اخرى لمن يحب هذا البلد ان
يواجهه بشفافيه ان هناك فشل منظومه امنيه
شديد وعلينا ان نعي ذلك علينا ان نتدارك
وهو ليس حديث هو بيزداد يعني هذا موجود
منذ ان تم تركيز الامن على الامن السياسي
منذ عهد حسني مبارك لما بتركز على الامن
السياسي وتسيب الكفاءات وتسيب الامن العام
ده بيكون بيبقى يعني بيدي مساحه اكبر لمن
لمن يريد ان يستغل هذه الثغرات بانه
يستغلها بسهوله اكبر وتزداد هذه العمليه
اكثر فنصبح في ما نحن فيه للاسف الشديد
ولن وكان من اهداف ثوره يناير هو اعاده
هذه المنظومه
ان تكون منظومه امنيه صحيحه وسليمه من اجل
الحفاظ على الوطن والمواطن وليس من اجل
الحفاظ على سلطه او كرسي او اشخاص بعين في
ظل هذه طبعا الابرياء من المجندين والضباط
الصغار وما الى ذلك طيب في ظل هذه الظروف
ومصر ترتقب وتنتظر ذكرى الخ من يناير في
اي ظروف مصر تستقبل هذه الذكرى في ظل
تتالي هذه العمليات في مصر هذا ما سنناقشه
في الجزء الثاني من هذه
الحلقه اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش التاثيرات المحتمله لتوالي
الهجمات التي تستهدف رجال الامن والمواقع
السياحيه في مصر ضيفي من القاهره السيد
محمود
عطيه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل تتالي هذه
العمليه
وتتابعها فينه بعد فينه وحينا بعد حين
ومصر تترقب في الايام القادمه احياء ذكرى
الخم وال من يناير اين الامن والذكرى تحل
بعد
ايام والله الامن الامن موجود الامن موجود
والحمد لله وصلنا الى مرحله كبيره جدا جدا
جدا اما عيد الشرطه القادم باذن الله في
يناير فسوف تحتفل به
مصر
بشرطتين كلهم ودي ذكرى عزيزه علينا منم
الاحتلال
الانجليزي ف ولا لا تمثل اي دعوه من دعوات
الفيسبوكيه والانترنت والكلام ده على
الوضع في مصر مصر اكبر من الكلام ده
بكتير كون ان
البعض بياخذ هذه الاشياء دليلا [__] في
مقارب لفكره واتجاهاته ف ده موضوع اخر
يعني ده موضوع اخر لكن الحمد لله احنا
قاعدين في مصر
والدنيا يعني على ما يرام اذا كان بيتخلل
هذا الكلام بعض العمليات الارهابيه فهذا
وارد ونحن نقر به تاثيره في السياحه لا
مافيش كلام انه مؤثر على السياحه ولكن ما
باليد دله هنعمل ايه ده موضوع دولي موضوع
عالمي والحمد لا احنا في طريقنا باذن الله
الانتهاء من هذا الكلام في القريب باذن
الله طيب تقول سيد محمود تقول ستحل ذكرى
عيد الشرطه ولكن نصائح كثيره وجهت للحكومه
والنظام المصري لا يجب الاعتماد فقط على
الحل الامني في معالجه الازمه السياسيه في
مصر اين المصالحه المصريه حتى تتجنب مصر
اي هزات قد تحدث نتيجه هذا الحدث او
ذاك
والله والله المصالحه الباب مفتوح يا
استاذ عبد القادر احنا كلنا مصريين وانا
كنت بتكلم في هذا الموضوع
امبارح في اخوه اخرين بيتكلموا في هذا
الموضوع حتى منهم اعضاء في البرلمان
الجديد بيتكلموا على عمل مصالحه شامله بكل
افراد الشعب لان كلنا مصريين ما عدا من
حمل السلاح ضد الدوله بس كده لكن هي
المسائل كلها احنا كلنا ما طلعناش من
بعضينا احنا كوحده واحده مصريين اهلا
وسهلا باي مصالحه واي مصري يخش تحت نظام
وعباءه الدوله ما فيش اي كلام وانا اشجع
هذا واتمنى هذا ما فيهاش اي كلام دكتور
ثروت برايك باي عين تنظر الحكومه والنظام
المصري الى الذكرى القادمه ذكرى ثوره الخم
من يناير طبعا بين التهويل وبين التهوين
من الاجواء التي تحيط بهذه الذكرى طبعا مع
مراعاه ما يجري من
عمليات
اي تستطيع ان تحلل ذلك من ردود افعال
النظام المرتعشه والمرعبه في واحيانا
بصوره غير مفهومه لمجرد قرب ذكرى ثوره
يناير العظيمه تجد من قبلها بثلاث اربع
اسابيع اما حملات اعتقال او تسريبات
مخابراتيه في الاعلام من خلال و جوه يعني
احترقت اما يعلنوا الندم او يدخلوا في
مهاترات لعده ساعات كانهم يعودوا ادراجهم
للثوره وبس المقصود ان هو يظهر في اخر
الجمله منهم بس يا ريت ما ننزل ش في 25
يناير كما ان قائد الانقلاب يظهر في احد
الخطب ويقول لو عايزيني امشي امشي بس ما
تنزلوش في حاله من الرعب دائما من هذه
الذكرى حتى لو لم يكن هناك دعوات فانا لم
ارى دعوات يعني كبيره للنزول
لكنها يعني بتعود بالمصريين وشباب
المصريين لذكرى كيفيه ت انتفض الشارع
المصري من اجل حريته وكرامته والبحث عن
العيش والحريه والكرامه الانسانيه فليها
يعني معاني ولها
يعني ذكرى جميله عند قلوب المصريين بيرتعش
منها اي نظام دكتاتوري لانه بيكون شب
بالنظام الذي انقلب عليه الم محمود عطيه
الا ينعمون منذ شهور ربما سنوات بحاله من
الامن والام كما يقول ضيفي من القاهره
وبالتالي علامه الثوره وعلام
الخوف نعم عده الاف منهم ينعمون بهذا
الامن والامان وهم الملتصقون
والملتحمة اخر وليس هناك امن والامان
والاطفال تخطف وال والعجائز يموتون على
ابواب المستشفيات لان ما بيدخلو هش في في
الاستقبال يعني اي امن واي امن الدوله لها
تعريفات مختلفه تماما عن تعريفات القله
القليله وهي عده الاف ان لم تكن يعني على
عدد الاصابع اليد الواحده الذين ينعمون
بهذا الامن والامان داخل مصر اما الدوله
الدول الحقيقيه اللي فيها امن وامان
فالامن والامان ده من لاصغر واحد في في
البلد من اصغر واحد في البلد لاكبر واحد
في البلد ثم ل الامن وال لم يعني لم يحدث
الا بفعل فاعل من
خين في 25 نا من يربط بين وتيره هذه
العمليات وما يتبعها من اجراءات امنيه
وبين محاوله التهويل والتخويف من ربما وضع
امني قد يبدو خطيرا متدهورا في حال
الاستجابه لاي دعوه في الذكره القادمه للخ
من يناير هل انت مع هذا الربط بين
الصورتين
نعم نعم انا مع هذا الربط لان يعني ما
يحدث ان هذا النظام كان له بعض الشعبيه
حينما قام ببعض الشعارات التي دغدغ بها
قلوب المصريون نتيجه اخطاء من كانوا في
السلطه في ذلك الوقت من وخاصه جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين فكان له بعض الشعبيه في
بادئ الامر ثم بدات تتاكل هذه الشعبيه مع
اتضاح ان كل ما كان يقوله هو هراء وهو
بالضبط يعني الثوره المضاده في في صوره
مجس الساده فبدا هذا فبدات تتاكل وتنتهي
هذه الشعبيه هو يشعر بذلك ان هو مخصص كل
اجهزه استخباراته وكل يعني جمع معلوماته
بدل ما تكون في اتجاه الارهاب في اتجاه
الامن السياسي فهو يعلم ذلك جيدا لذلك
يرتعد من هذه الذكرى يرتعد من اي دعوات في
هذه الذكرى لانه يعلم ان ان ان الشارع
يعني او معظم الشارع عشان نكون دقيقين في
التحليل يعني على شفا يعني الانفجار
وينتظر هذه اللحظات كما حدث في في 2011
وربما اكثر لان القمع ازداد وحالات يعني
والانهيار الاقتصادي ازداد على ما كان حتى
في 2011 ف الحاله النفسيه مستعده تماما
لموجه ثريه
قادمه
نح لجنه الدفاع والامن القومي في مجلس
الشورى المصري السابق شكرا جزيلا لك كما
اشكر ضيفي من القاهره كان معي عبر الهاتف
محمود عطيه المحامي والمنسق العام لائتلاف
مصر فوق الجميع ل باذ
[موسيقى]
الله